here's a real tear
rounded together we'll rally through
this one oh god dude
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by ronda rousey
she's a former bantamweight champion and
the first ever woman to be inducted in
the ufc hall
of fame she's an actress author olympian
wwe raw women's champion and not to be
outdone
she also has a pretty popping youtube
channel as well check it out
subscribe but first things first the
wings of death
ronda rousey welcome to the show thank
you for having me this has been a long
time coming
too long and you know i know that wings
have always been
a part of your post-fight celebratory
feast
i'm curious how spicy do you like them
though you know what
i like them spicy enough where i can
actually still taste everything else
so i'd say there's got to be like a
balance to it and uh i guess we're going
way to the
far side of that balance so i'll tell
you where the sweet spot
where the sweet spot's at and when we
have patched the threshold
we'll just rip into it right away just
rip into it yep
i don't know if you've seen this
technique before of
hot wing eating is that a thing for you
not the
not the first bones you've split i don't
think
a good one all right so
this is the ranch
[Music]
it's pretty good on ranch i mean uh yeah
i got around
it's the blue cheese
[Music]
[Music]
wow
i got to put my hair back before i got
too saucy
so first my compliments to your team
because you've recreated the hot one set
to the point that when i walked into the
studio and saw the monitor i thought i
was a ghost because i was looking at the
set but i couldn't see myself so i want
to say that
first and my guess is that you're
probably shooting from browsy acres your
sustainable ranch in southern california
where you live off the land and take
care of some 30-plus farm animals
how much of this lifestyle is motivated
by just being practical and being
responsible and how much of it is just
pure
doomsday prepper impulse um it
started as doomsday prepper but it's
like
morphed into just kind of like our
contribution to society is to try and
like
be as self-sustaining and less taxing
from everybody else as possible but
first it was like reoccurring zombie
dreams i'm like what am i gonna do
like my mom called me the other day and
she's like i don't know what i'm gonna
do this election
i might move out of the country i don't
know what's going on
i'm so stressed out i'm like mom like
i'm prepared for zombies okay that's
like a 10.
all right life is great it is like one
president
you don't like is like a two or a three
like i'm definitely prepared for two or
three
so it kind of like if you're prepared
for zombies you just kind of feel like
everything else is like ah
you know i could deal with it
[Music]
it's unique your intimate understanding
of human anatomy in terms of
which bones and which joints break the
easiest
is both fascinating and terrifying
and your experience what are in fact the
most vulnerable pain points for a
fighter
like the elbow only goes a certain way
the knee only goes a certain way and the
ankle only goes a certain way
they're not like a very durable joint so
it only takes like a few pounds of
pressure to dislocate somebody's elbow
it actually started back in my judo days
my mom
her philosophy was if you throw somebody
they can just not count it
if you get somebody in a pin they could
just tell you to get up
if you get somebody in a choke they
could tell you to get up and the person
takes a deep breath
and they're fine but if you get somebody
in an arm bar and you break their arm
they don't count it the other person
only has one arm and if you lose to that
person then you deserve to lose
so you should just get really good at
arm bars on that note how would you
break down the components of a perfect
arm bar
like a lot of people would teach oh
you're supposed to
turn your toes in and squeeze with your
knees or eyes always cross my ankles
and bring my heels into my butt and open
my knees
i remember like watching the commentary
one of my fights and one of the
commentaries were like she just needs to
squeeze her knees a little bit and i'm
like shut the [ __ ] up you don't even
know what you're talking about okay
mamba's perfect [ __ ] you
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so most people got to know you as the
face of ufc but when you were 16 years
old you were actually the number one
ranked jidoka in the world
and had competed in two olympics by your
21st birthday
literally translated from japanese is
the gentle way
judo is steeped in philosophical
principles about using
body and mind efficiently can you
enlighten me on judo's core
interplay between the violent and the
gentle
it basically comes from people fighting
each other in like samurai armor
so that's why there's no striking in
judo because why would you punch or kick
somebody that's covered in
armor that's why like the pins and
throws
count as a win because if you could like
get somebody to the ground and pin them
you can pull out a knife or whatever and
stab them or something like that
the gentle way means nobody dies like
you're supposed to be fine like i said
you know you can
like in a judo tournament you can have
like five seven matches in a day and
you're not supposed to really get
injured even though you know
[ __ ] happens but like it's a gentle way
as in it's like not part of warfare
warfare anymore it's a sport
[Music]
angry goat i like that name i got six
goats
the sweetness was like in the middle at
first i would taste like barbecue like
hints
barbecue then it was sweet and then now
it's like the spices coming in
yeah it's got layers man
so you have a really strong
understanding of the economics of
fighting and you can even in a more
broadly way really explain the business
of sports in layman's terms
between the ufc wwe in hollywood
which industry is the most unpleasant to
negotiate a contract in
oh my gosh with the ufc i mean i always
like i'm very much
about betting on myself i would you like
the back end you like the background
i care about the back end like pay me
whatever you think is fair
all i really care about is you know um
having
some stake in how well this does and
i'll make sure it does like
really [ __ ] well i've never really
cared about money so i never really had
a problem
with anybody anybody that hires me is
like [ __ ] yeah she doesn't like
i'm not really a nickel or diming
anybody i'm just like yeah like you know
i have people that help me out that
stuff and i'm like okay just let me know
when i can sign a thing and then i'ma
show up and i'm gonna do i'm just gonna
do [ __ ] awesome and everyone's gonna
be happy and
so far it's been working out
[Music]
no milk in my mouth
just amazing technique oh
all right rhonda we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham where we do a deep dive on our
guests instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context did i
post these things
yeah yeah
so it's crazy how you endured as mma
fighter professional wrestler
only to severely injure yourself on a tv
set
i was on doing 9-1-1 and they had like
this episode
or like a tsunami or whatever like wiped
out
in l.a and
literally like the first day of shooting
we're like down
in mexico filming in the tanks that they
filmed titanic in
and the director who's like okay you're
gonna open this
boat door and then come out say your
lines and then throw this [ __ ] in the
water
i'm like cool so then i come out and i
push up the the door but i'm like
shorter than him and i'm going up steps
at the same time so it feels like the
door is like
going i guess it just kind of like
paused
on the way out it like slammed on my
hand and i was like
[ __ ] i like hit all my lines and then i
grab
all that [ __ ] and i threw it out the
boat and i looked down my hand
and like my [ __ ] finger is off
i'm very good at like shutting down and
not like showing pain when like shit's
not going well for me
so i kind of covered my hand up and i
like like turned to look at like the
direct everybody like behind
the camera and i'm like yeah um i'm
gonna pop
my fingers off and then they had to like
put me in the ambulance
and it just so happened that in the
emergency room or whatever was like a
hand specialist that used to train with
my husband down at like alliance or
something like that and he was like oh
my god what's up and i'm like you know
that's my
finger [ __ ] falling off and um
yeah i have like a plate and like eight
screws look at this thing
wow and you know this and i finally got
it back down to a fist which is all i
cared about you know i don't care about
flicking people off pretty like i feel
like the extra knuckle makes it more
intense
this is hotter than i would prefer like
at a restaurant
because i feel like the um the hot sauce
is really overpowering and that
i don't really get to taste the chicken
or anything else that much
so like it's above my preference but not
like above my ability
if that makes sense oh wait i already
have celebrities
so i know that you have a soft spot in
your heart for anime it's an art form
now that's really gone mainstream it's
very commonplace now to see
athletes from nba players to ufc stars
draw inspiration from shows like dragon
ball z
what in your opinion makes anime special
as a storytelling genre compared to like
the traditional american
cartoon fair that we grew up on what i
loved about dragon ball z
that was so different than um anything
else that i'd seen
in uh like american cartoons was
all of their powers they had to like
really earn and work hard for
and it wasn't like bruce wayne had to
get like a better buy a better gadget
because he's rich or
you know superman was already tapped out
or like this is somebody's powers
because something happened to them
i think because i was working so hard to
be like a judo master myself i thought
it was really cool to like
see something like that about like
martial arts i think now like a lot of
people are coming out they're like i
love dragon ball z because it's like you
kind of had to hold it in and
not talk about it your whole life just
like i had to not talk about like judo
tournaments or anything else like that
so it's like
it's like a big coming out party for
everybody that are
you know a couple decades removed from
discovering it
ghost pepper oh [ __ ] this is the one
that's coming to get me huh
i i literally do not want to clear my
throat because i feel like i could hurt
myself
wait till you get to the next one
that was a sharp left turn there's
definitely some like
protests in my stomach i don't even know
which was better the ranch or the blue
cheese because
they're there purely for survival
purposes
right and who can focus in a time like
this
so rhonda your name is synonymous with
championship belts and hollywood red
carpets but i know that you had to grind
it out with a handful of odd jobs along
the way
what was your biggest customer pet peeve
back when you were working on the floor
at home depot
home depot there's a lot of like weird
[ __ ] at the home depot
all right i ring things out with the
little barcode thing you know
so if you bring me some random piece of
[ __ ] whatever that could have been
from anywhere
in this entire warehouse and it doesn't
have a barcode on it right
don't get all huffy and puffy with me
when i have to break out the binder
and look for this [ __ ] and like call
somebody else be like do you know what
this [ __ ] thing is
and they're like now i'm like stop
[ __ ] beatboxing
okay i am a minimum wage
apron wearing dealing with your ass type
of [ __ ] right now
like i'm a human i am not a robot i
can't just scan the [ __ ] with my eyes
like like let's calm down here
my nose is running so spicy all right
are you ready to move on to the next one
yes be very careful with this one this
is the bomb beyond insanity
the bomb beyond insanity [ __ ] yeah
and it's a it's a wild one it's a big
step up between these sauces just fair
warning because i know you're very
shoot first asked questions later with
the break and this
in the clean rip i'm just looking out
for you rhonda
in your corner on this one whoa it's
going down
[Music]
i like immediately felt it in my nose
for cruel cool man
it actually burns my stomach and my nose
and my throat at the same time
this is lemon juice because gordon
ramsay did it and i was wondering if it
worked
oh you saw the gordon ramsay episode i
don't think it helps
gordon you failed me i licked my own
lips and it hurt
yeah here's a real tear
rounded together we'll rally through
this one oh god dude
how would you describe the appeal of
world of warcraft to someone who's never
played the game
sorry if i'm like annoying people by
chewing my mouth open i'm just really
trying to get like some [ __ ]
circulation in my mouth
[Music]
um i think the wow has stuff in it that
really appeals to everybody you know
it's like
you can have can i have something that
like a thing that doesn't have the hot
sauce on it so i don't like rub it on my
face accidentally please
um thanks dude thank you
um but like world of warcraft has like
story mode i literally broke my blue my
nose and the rest of my nose started
burning from the inside
that's how you can like play by yourself
like solo if you're into like rpg stuff
but it adds like
really great pvp like mode with it
hosa has like pet battles which is
basically like pokemon and
like turn-based battles and that's like
a really great community too
you know like everybody there just just
like wants to help everybody else out
a lot of people have been playing for
like over a decade you know
there's a lot of people that are just
into it as like a lifestyle
and we're happy to welcome other people
into that lifestyle
um my tears are burning my face like i
feel like
the hot sauce went in like
my nose i sniffed it up and went into my
tear duct and it was like coming out
burning my face
dousing it give me that milk
definitely not as hot as the last one
but i'm not enjoying myself
right exactly so outside of your
accomplishments in the octagon you've
shown yourself to be a natural on screen
appearing in a handful of network tv
shows and major movie franchises like
fast and furious
can you give me one uniquely meathead
quality
of the expendables set like when all of
those action stars get together as like
the craft service just
lean meats rice and protein smoothies oh
there are weights on set
they would literally be like lifting
weights and doing bands and like
curling things like between takes
it was a it's a cool little boys club to
be part of and i quite
enjoyed everybody i miss you guys yeah i
remember like we had like this thing we
had like run up this roof a million
times
and i was in training camp for the
second time i
beat easter's ass and i was like oh this
is awesome i can like use this
as like my sprints for the day i'm like
every single take like spray
spray gonna get my sprints in and
they're like yeah you need to like
not be all the way over there you need
to like dial it back like
10 notches like everybody's gotta be
rushing together into the helicopter
sports neighbor was really cool about
saying get in the chopper for us got a
really huge kick out of that saying that
in person
no one wanted to compete with me they
were just being like really sweet very
mentor like i learned a lot from
everybody
for sure
[Music]
last dab apollo i'm afraid
she is cheers rhonda
[Music]
okay ronda rousey here we are at the
final bell of our 10-round fight against
the wings of death and i can think of
only one way to properly close this
thing out
in our five years nearly 200 episodes of
doing hot ones i don't think that we've
ever had a guest with a deeper
more profound connection to the hot wing
the reports of you eating as many as 50
wings as part of a post-fight ritual
and i've heard you explain the action of
splitting bones and comparing it to like
the
the carnal nature of a heated bloody ufc
fight so now that we're here at the end
the world has to know
why are wings so sentimental to you and
pound for pound
what is the greatest chicken wing memory
of your life
this is definitely painful my inside of
my nostrils are burning the most which
is very surprising
to me and um dude
poor trav is gonna have to deal with
like the hottest
farts in marriage tonight like
oh man when i was in training camp or
fights
i would always always crave hot wings it
just kind of became like
associated with like victory and
happiness was like
the post-winning wing i will show you
um my happiest memory with halloween
my friend eric williams took this for me
this is
the best plate of wings i've ever had
right here and um this was
after i beat [ __ ] koaya in brazil
went total rocky for on that [ __ ] dana
and lorenzo
they actually flew down the sauce from
anchor bar
they flew in a chef from sao paulo they
had these wings
all specially made from a chef from a
different city from
sash from a different country it was the
best and i always like
had the happiest memories with with hot
wings so
this is definitely going to be another
one of those at the doctor top
but you know it's up there this is
definitely we are
honored to be in the conversation you
guys have to hang that
priceless piece of artwork up in the
louvre and look at you
ronda rousey knocking out some of the
hottest chicken wings in the history of
planet earth
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you
this camera or that camera or whatever
kind of setup you guys have going on in
that perfect
hot one set replica let the people know
what you have going on in your life
uh this is like the opposite of like a
talk show what do you like you go on and
you're like oh i have this thing to
promote like
we have a million different things in
development that actually can't talk
about so i have
nothing to talk about except for how
amazing no d dmb productions is
any production company i've set up this
whole set
this is actually my uh
my bedroom and the bed is over there for
sound absorption and this is a dresser
and we are the the best
smallest up incomingest production
company
on the planet i mean the baddest why
didn't i miss that opportunity
um but yeah check out my um my channel
on youtube
ronda rousey just in it for the sport
salute my friend thank you so much for
doing this
thank you for having me i'm gonna go um
[ __ ] shards my pelvis
oh thank you i'm gonna have to apologize
mr brown he won't be able to eat my ass
for a week
marriage that could be your sound bite
bye
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say thank
you so much
for watching today's video and join me
in welcoming
the newest member of the hot ones hot
sauce family this is the last dab apollo
the only sauce made with the apollo
pepper
the latest and greatest from the twisted
mind of smoking ed curry
it is the hottest last dab we've ever
made and the people who will taste it
first
are the subscription box subscribers who
will get this one
in october's box for everyone else
probably sometime later in october
heatness.comheatness.com to learn more
about the last dab apollo
moment of silence for the last dab
triple xxx but it's okay
all new beginnings must come from some
other beginning's end